hi hamish hi samantha hi morgan
there is so much i want to say about
this year's i watch the whole thing in
two days but i don't want to spoil
anything so i just want to say
father paul
um how much fun was it for you bringing
this character to life and me because
there are so many layers
oh it was such a joy i mean these
scripts were like phenomenal i was like
just let me
let me just let me just wear these
scripts and walk around in them let that
be my my toga party for the next four
months i just wear these pages because
the language was so gorgeous i just
wanted to clothe myself in them
that's amazing very visual and i can see
you doing that um samantha i can't have
father paul without bev helping him with
his mission
yeah why is this relationship so
important of ev
um i think because
since
bev is such a
a woman of faith that
that being approved of and being a part
of
you know
the church in this way and being this
close to
to father paul is you know she just she
feels important she feels like
she matters and uh and that's really
important to beth to feel like she
matters yeah um how much fun is it for
you guys working on a show obviously
mike flanagan is this master of horror
we've come to love his work so much of
course the hunting of hill house and fly
manor um how much fun is it working on a
show with so many twists and turns like
when you're reading these scripts are
you like my god
yes
yes
like i've had the pleasure of working on
a hill house as well and when those came
out i mean
just turn the lights off like just read
it scare yourself
you i mean he could scare you through a
script on a computer so it was
thrilling
hamish were you uh successfully creeped
out
yeah totally i mean well it's also the
thing it's yeah i guess the genre is the
horror genre or the terror genre but
it's really a thriller i mean it's the
page turner genre uh like you just keep
flipping the pages so often i'll tell
you how bad of an actor i am so
i'll get a script and i'm like find i go
to the find my character name and i'd
say their line their line they're like
oh i got a fair number of lines this one
this one i could care less what i had to
say i just wanted to know what bev was
going to say next or zach was going to
say next or that cake character was
going to say next you know he's a great
writer it was real so listen you know
this island seemingly at the very
beginning i mean obviously it's not
through hard times but it seems like an
idyllic place to live and then obviously
that turns very quickly i want to know
how you would handle the events on this
island if this was happening to you
would you just crawl in a ball would you
try to escape what would you do
i think i'd behave really heroically
can you be the hero save the day
it's kind of my instinct what do you
think is that i would do well
in this kind of disaster sam
uh i'd be on the first boat off first
vote off
yeah do you think hamish would be the
hero of the day i have no doubt i have
no doubt that hamas should be the hero
of the day and he would probably you
know come to punish me for fleeing
just really complete the circle
yeah you know samantha working on
hunting up hill house you know when you
read this and you know it has that same
vibe what are you excited for fans of my
plan against previous series when it
comes to this what are you excited for
fans to see
uh
as always i'm excited for them to meet
the world you know to be in the world
that he's built and to meet this group
of people i think one thing that his
fans
and i include myself and that love so
much is that you you learn to love these
people you know these people you care
what happens to them it's not just
you know fodder for
you know who's gonna die
incredibly or who's who's not or it's
that you you love them and because they
matter it it raises the stakes so so
highly
is it safe to tease that no one is safe
on this island
you can say that you could see no one's
safe on the island i mean that's kind of
like you sit down to
if you're gonna if you're gonna binge
something in the autumn
chances are
you're binging unsafe people
that's a good point it's true and i have
to say like it really doesn't truly feel
like fall to me unless i'm getting a
series from my plan again i mean can we
just admit that at this point can we
just make sure that it's always the case
just yeah
absolutely you guys uh both creep me out
uh congratulations you did such a great
job but i did love both of your
characters so much so congrats on the
series thank you so much
you